Terry you can't tell me what a straight
line is I think that's I think that's
pretty solid proof no all right
for me
all right we're gonna go to the front
okay okay
uh
we'll go to the sidewalk over here you
got anything on your purse any weapons
or anything you mind if I just check it
real quick
right here
um
you know we're actually gonna we'll just
walk back here to the bed of your truck
right yeah
um
okay you've had how many beers did you
say you've had today or drinks three or
four okay
um and how long ago was that
uh about an hour plus okay all right
just throughout the time like from like
six to
229 okay so between that time at least
three to four okay that's been hanging
with my buddies I'm not from here gotcha
it's been here working he came out
hanging with them okay you want to go
with some
hang out
have a couple of drinks we went out
the dad went to Taco Bell my other
brother wanted to go home I was like all
right no problem I'll bring you home
okay
um yeah man you're driving's pretty bad
your eyes are super glossy
um I guess not Blues coming from you so
I want to run some sobriety tests on you
all right that cool all right man so the
first one's just gonna be the eye test
for this one we're gonna have your sand
feet together hands of your sides all
right you wear glasses or contacts
all right follow it with your eyes and
your eyes only okay
that's kind of hard to do right there
way out of my vision yeah well just just
do it as best you can right now
well just uh keep your eyes on my finger
okay
trying to look but
all right yeah just keep your eyes on
the tip my finger okay
forth then too many times like it's
getting a little dizzy over here you
know okay boy
we're gonna do it until my test is done
okay all right sorry sir
this is like a
past the time limit they can do this for
yeah there's no time on them okay
there's no time on it
he's hanging with boys yeah it is it's
early in the morning yeah but there's
there's no time limit all right man so
that that's the eye test we got two more
tests we're gonna go through okay uh the
next one's gonna be the walk and turn
test so for this test I'm just gonna
give you a picture a line going down the
center of the sidewalk here
[Music]
[Laughter]
straight line
sure sure thing man
that's good man
go over here
yeah so I'm asking you what do you want
me to do as a straight line like can you
give me definitive have you had any
psychedelic drugs today man no I'm not
all right I'm just trying to be
straightforward with you bro just
picture a straight line going down going
on the sidewalk
might be obscured
might be upskirt
s okay listen yeah if I stand right here
and you start here and he stands right
here that straight line is obscured all
right walk down the I want I'm gonna
have you walk down the middle of the
sidewalk
I don't know how I can explain this any
clear so I want to have you get in the
starting position
I'm gonna put heavier put your left foot
I was just trying to ask I'm at I'm
gonna have you put your left foot on the
line I'm gonna put your right foot in
front of your left foot touching Heel To
Toe left right right foot in front of
your left foot
right foot in front of your left foot
right right foot so I said starting as
the Left Foot Right Foot
in front of your left foot arms at your
sides this is the starting position stay
in this position while I explain the
instructions okay man
I feel so sustained do you understand
left or right yes sir okay stay in this
starting position while I explain the
instructions okay when I say begin
you're going to take nine Heel To Toe
steps down that line it's going to look
just like this
what
one
two
three when you get to nine you're gonna
take a series of small steps and you're
gonna go back down that line take nine
steps again just like this one
two three you're gonna go all the way to
nine count each step out loud and keep
your hands at your sides
you understand
left to right
right I want you to do the test just how
I explain those instructions
left right nine I'm back nine
you're gonna take nine heal the toe
steps going down the line
my foot to my right foot nine steps
you're gonna step you're going to step
nine times down that line and then
you're gonna turn around
left two right nine steps per round come
back to another one do you want me to
explain it again what what's your what's
your first name Tanner Tanner Tanner all
right last name Watson just for the sake
of redundancy I can explain this to you
again
clarification
Left Foot Right first
you're right I'm asking you right first
right
left foot
left foot Tanner you're gonna start left
foot
Tanner I'm asking you 10 foot I don't
have to raise my voice even higher
Tanner I'm asking you left foot
what's up do you want to continue with
the instructions
I'm asking you left foot you told me
left foot I cannot explain this any
clearer to you you can okay I'm asking
you left or right foot I have to go back
you're gonna have your right foot in
front of your left foot so left left
foot and then right front your right
foot is in front of your left foot
nine steps Tanner that's insane
and then what all right Tanner turn
around place your hands behind your back
okay
all right is there anything in the car
you need Tanner
I think my phone's in there
your wallet is in the car is uh with you
uh driving intoxicating
do you ever need fruit for that or
Perry you can't tell me what a straight
line is I think that's I think that's
pretty solid proof no all right that's
too many times I got you thank you